all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath live this is the show
where you get to ask your favorite
comedians your favorite questions about
comedy and today we have one of my
favorite comedians a guy that shares the
same spirit in creating your own success
in this game only focusing on what you
can control and helping other people do
the same so that is the whole goal of
this interview is to hopefully you leave
here with a new perspective on how you
can stop waiting for someone else's
approval and just start getting ish done
so without further ado welcome to hot
breath live Mike Cannon everyone welcome
my cannon everyone thanks for having me
dude I appreciate it and that you've
you've been doing the show a while right
yeah I've been doing this show like four
years now because it's a perfectly
appropriate title for a quarantine but I
am NOT brush my teeth in a timely manner
once since this whole thing started yeah
it just gets more and more timely so I I
stumbled upon something exciting here I
think and we've I mean we've interviewed
a lot of the people and you're special
like Robert Kelley and like rich Voss
have been on the show as well so like
we've nice we've we've run in some
similar circles but it's good to finally
get you on here I'm excited yeah sure
same so everyone in the comments go
ahead and start posting your questions I
am going to selfishly ask some of my own
questions first because as I was
producing my own comedy special and
looking at what other people were doing
and how other people were doing things
mics popped up actually on my birthday
January 24th is when this was actually
released and I'm always inspired and I
always like resonate with comics who are
like on that independent hustle just
looking for ways they can make it happen
themselves so in jumping into your
personal experience with your comedy
special I mean let's kind of go from
like beginning to end in terms of even
like first
like my specials called the trophy
husband I clearly had like a theme
around it and had a vision for it what
maybe hurt well I guess first introduce
yourself to the hot breath averse and
then get into like your special and how
the idea even came to be sure yeah I'm
Mike Ken and I'm a New York city-based
they end up comedian I've been doing it
a little over 11 years at this point I
released an album through 800 pound
gorilla Records on in when was that
September of 2017 so that was my first
kind of foray into you know showcasing
that I am a stand-up comedian because
I've been on radio I've been on some TV
I do podcasts and all that stuff and
then when people would ask me where can
they see my stand-up there'd be you know
a limited opportunity aside from you
know poorly shot YouTube videos and
stuff like that so the impetus for the
first album was to just get something
down have my first hour that I was
touring with as a headliner and I was
proud of it put that out and then for
the second one I just you know obviously
as a comedian you want to grow each and
every time you want to do something a
little bit different you want to offer
something something more so you know no
no networks we're knocking down my door
I have a good relationship with all
these people but at this point they're
like listen you know you're a good comic
and that doesn't say much these days you
can't we can't sell we can't sell you
based on quality comedy apparently
anymore so you got a you got to start
you know getting your name out there and
become become in need you know a lot of
the people that are getting specials now
are already famous they have an audience
to draw from it helps secure the
financial back you know the confidence
of your financial backers so I decided
to sit out and and do this do they do is
special and the idea the idea for life
begins in terms of you know you you know
and results I assume right yeah for sure
he's been on the show as well yeah oh
cool yeah I love Andrew I loved what he
did with the four-for-one the his first
special which was kind of a mini piece
and it was you know you know for clubs
and one night and doing spots all around
the city it had a few interstitials of
him in the cab and talking comedy with a
couple other comedians and stuff like
that and I liked the idea of presenting
I'm kind of you know at a smaller scale
so to speak and a little bit different
from the typical uncut hour-long special
and yeah I I have the I'm lucky and
fortunate enough to work at the Comedy
Cellar and the story how I got in there
is obviously pretty insane and it
involves several of my heroes so that's
that was immediately where my mind went
to to start Oh to almost like tell the
story of how you got to where you are
today yeah I mean you know the the
cellar and it was a little bit
tongue-in-cheek right because the cellar
is is like a very huge character in
comedy at this point you know Louie
Louie is shot had show around there Pete
Holmes did crashing around there
you know countless people have shot it
in in a various form of medium I think
truTV did a full you know documentary
even on it so it's been the it's been
the topic of conversation for a really
long time so tongue-in-cheek I decided
to share my you know my story is if
anybody could possibly give a [ __ ] but
what makes it interesting are we allowed
to curse them yeah I know it was just
funny of just yeah you know the story
about how I got in was I happened to be
hanging out there with my buddy Chris de
Stefano and his daughter I was having
dinner with them and Chris was supposed
to do an opening set for Colin Quinn as
he was working out his new show red red
state blue state and unfortunately after
the Colin had a heart attack he's okay
now
this isn't breaking news he had a heart
attack and I was asked to cover and I
had a great set from that I ended up
getting my audition oh my gosh
yeah it were because also on your
special there's like Jim Norton there's
rich Fosters Bobby Kelly were they there
oh and Keith Robinson as well don't any
profits yeah but they they weren't there
but Bobby Bobby Voss keep to a lesser
extent just because you know I haven't I
haven't necessarily been wildly social
with him until recently cool but like
especially Jim especially Bobby really
have helped me out early on in my career
by giving the opportunity on the radio
and on podcast so and not to mention I'm
a huge ridiculous geek for tough crowd
you know central to Opie and Anthony I
mean
red you know Norton before I met him was
my favorite comedian and that's not to
say he's since ruined it with his
personality nob just say he was like he
was my favorite comedian I was obsessed
with all of these guys I read the book
so I've been like laser focused on the
cellar and the table and all that kind
of surrounds it for a really long time
so to get a mini tough crowd reunion on
my own special it's kind of a a wild
pipe dream come true and how how did you
actually start to get the actual
tangible pieces together so did it first
start off with the idea I want to do
something that's more kind of like an
opening skit that has interstitials
throughout and then did it evolve into
like okay well what cameras do we need
who's going to like direct this you know
like that process so the the idea was me
my but I was just kind of like you know
I'm in you know a million group texts my
phone is an absolute nightmare it's
constantly buzzing people are you know
it's it's comedians throwing bits it's
other comedians telling me they want to
kill themselves and then my friends for
not understanding what's happening in my
life so it's just a constant
you know onslaught of messages but I was
I was going back and forth with my
buddies Brendon Sagle oh and Mike Feeney
- very very funny comedians and I was
just kind of giving my my pipe dream
scenario of what that what would be cool
to get right like all five of these guys
imagine if they were in my special how
ridiculous would that be and they're
like they were the ones that were like
yeah I kind of think you could do that
and I was like now they would never do
it and like you do radio with these guys
all the time you have a relationship
you're friendly with them like just ask
and so I ended up pitching the idea to
Schultz actually because yeah I know
Yanis did his special with Andrew and I
was like oh you know that would be cool
I say I feel like I need to level up a
bit here so maybe having somebody you
know having Andrews name will will help
get some eyes on it and stuff like that
and I pitched him the idea and he liked
it also said he thought we should go in
a different direction which might be a
future project but this I had so I had
it so stuck in my craw that I was like
all right well I'm gonna actually just
take from Andrews book and instead of
waiting for him I'll just do it myself
and then
do we will do another thing maybe later
you know so right after that I know I
knew this guy Mike Lavin he's homeless
pimp on Instagram I follow him he yeah
he's so talented man his eye is I mean
his photographs are unreal just just
check out his photographs we could just
see that this guy sees the world in a
very unique and beautiful way and I know
I you know he had done some some other
doc you stuff for comedy shot some like
sizzles for live shows and so I knew he
I knew he could make a film and edit
some stuff together and then I met I
pitched him the idea and he turns out he
was a huge ona fan he's a huge tough
crowd fan he's exactly
he's got the exact type of Asperger's
that I do like he's just locked it to
everything that I said he was like boom
boom boom he saw it from from the moment
didn't want to change a thing and just
was in and basically you know this we
were talking before and you you asking
me if I was comfortable talking numbers
yeah with spent and all that stuff and
this is where I get extremely fortunate
and I don't think I'm I'm a typical case
where I pitched this to Mike who has his
own equipment
who does this that who knows how to edit
who knows you know who does this all for
a living and has some really cushy gigs
that that float him to where this wasn't
gonna be his you know cash cow so he
took this on as a passion project and
immediately was like hey man whatever
you need we'll do it we'll figure out
the money later Wow okay bunny I gave
him was actually just a pretty I mean
because he put in so much work I gave
him a pretty decent percentage from the
door when when we shot okay cool is
there music give music playing or is
that another reminder should I turn that
down yeah let me is it I want to love
somebody is that what's playing it's the
only music you could play on a Tuesday
at 11:00 a.m. one sec so everyone
comment with your questions we're gonna
get to him soon Julio I see yours
but um yes are jumping at no no no
worries at all I was just like wait is
that I want to love somebody going I was
wondering in the background because I
like my shoulder started
move into it it was like oh if I feel it
yeah but it's funny how when you I
learned that from filming my own special
with just setting the intention first
then the pieces almost just start to
gravitate towards you but I feel like as
comedians we can get in this like we
comedians aren't great at like a growth
mindset of like well this is possible or
what else is possible and I think people
like you and like Andrew Schultz have
opened up our minds to thinking bigger
but it is like mine kind of came to be I
was like well I'm 10 years into comedy
I'm just going to record an album and
then a fan of the podcast heard me
talking about the album and was like hey
I have a production company we can just
film it as a special so it's kind of
like these pieces fall into place but
you first have to almost like set the
intent for them or have to open that
door for it to open to you in a sense
yeah hundred percent I think you know we
I'm no filmmaker so I understand like I
have a decent eye for things and I help
the editing you know with with Mike
during the whole process but I handed I
handed the keys to him because he has
that he has that ability but I do think
that like it's it's that Coppola thing
right where he started you start
shooting before you even have the money
to make the movie I think Louie told a
story about hearing that you know a
Coppola started shooting what's the
Apocalypse Now he started shooting that
movie before he even had the financing
for it incredible yeah so you know it's
one of those things where listen it
doesn't work out all the time and
obviously there's a lot of sad stories
that go with that more more than
positive but if you're if you're gonna
do something you might as well dive in
and as it as a comedian as a self-hating
person I don't like asking for help
that's that's where I'm at my most
uncomfortable so the idea for me to even
ask my heroes if they would sit for 10
minutes and and do what they do best
which is verbally trash me that was a
nightmare situation that was the hardest
part of the entire thing
and when it actually came to I mean it
looks great first off and clearly yeah
Mike has a clear eye for lighting and
all of that so he would be I guess
someone else to talk about like the
specs with as opposed to like the actual
so um yeah maybe we'll maybe we'll talk
to him about those but in terms of like
your side of it and preparing the
material because I know what you said 11
years in but you recorded an album just
a few years ago yeah so yeah I mean what
was that process like yeah I earned over
the material pretty quick actually I was
uh I was pretty happy with myself
because you know it took it took me nine
years to write the first hour and not
not just to write an hour of material
because anybody can write an hour of
material but the hour is the shaping of
it right as the editing is the somatic
through-line is trying to figure out a
show because you could you know I'm one
of those people where I'm a bit
long-winded I'm also you know and I'm
very imagery based so I like to paint a
picture with it with with my words a
little bit so I'm not like I can't just
slap sixty minutes of jokes together and
have it be entertaining if I'm talking
up there it has to have some sort of if
not theme a through line or or flow to
it that almost like it plays it plays as
a complete piece as opposed to just a
fractured thing slept together yeah and
did you find it a lot of it started out
as like individual pieces you then kind
of had to start to weave together in a
sense yeah yeah for sure and a lot of
the stuff a lot of the individual pieces
didn't even fit so some of the stuff
that I had I had 60 minutes of material
for this second one for life begins
before it was even called life begins
before my wife told me she was pregnant
so I had I was I was ready to go I was
ready to shoot something that was a
similar tone to my first album I think
it just kicked in so is you know more or
less of the the manchild should of you
know doing drugs do it you know drinking
too much and having having this
long-term girlfriend despite be or wife
at that point despite being a you know a
piece of [ __ ]
but then my wife you know I
overseas I went to the Middle East to
perform for the troops which that's my
closer well it's like that into a seven
and a half minute piece and obviously
the my wife being pregnant and then
having our son was such a major life
event that it I threw out about thirty
minutes of material oh you threw out
like thirty minutes after this new
chapter of your life came to be yeah I
mean a lot of it was just like I'm not
ready for a kid I'll never have a kid
classic premature ass yeah that's that's
where my material is right now yeah I'm
married but don't want kids and all that
you know that type of deal I mean and I
wanted it it's more than I think my
material was more or less coming out of
the insecurity of whether or not I can
handle it so I think a lot I think
that's a lot of my of my comedy which
people you know it's easy to
misinterpret especially now in in the
era of taking everything literally is is
a lot of my stuff is showing my
overreaction and showing how you know
ridiculous I can be in certain
situations so when I'm like slamming a
point home that I am 100 percent correct
the undertone of that is isn't it
ridiculous how correct I think I'm being
okay that's great self-awareness as well
I heard you say in an interview that as
soon as you like stopped trying to be
funny and just started trying to be
authentic on stage that's when you
really started to find creative momentum
yeah I think that's true I'm just you
know I'm I'm very personal I've tried to
write jokes from from a different
perspective aside from my own you know
when you start comedy you try on a lot
of different outfits right yeah right
you're basically like what kind of
comedian am I gonna be and I am I an
absurdist you know they go up there with
an orange and like eat it and then throw
it at a kid and lower sighs it's like I
make then you do a one-liner and you're
like oh I could barely write so you know
that you write a story and you're like
nope nobody finds me interesting enough
to hang on for about 11 minutes so you
have to like finding your voice is more
or less cobbling together your ability
your natural abilities and
trying to you know make it kind of
congeal into one thing and I think I did
that when you know it you could hear you
could hear parts of it on my first album
I'm still happy with it I still think
there's some really good stuff on it but
I think the real like turnover in terms
of me knowing how to speak about my life
and about me personally came with my
second hour
what was that tipping point with your
writing and this could tie into Liam
Harvey asked actually uh what made you
grow faster and better as a joke writer
it's interesting man because you know
every every six months I think I've
figured it out and like six months ago I
should have quit like that's my mindset
every six months it's like alright now I
got it
like I'm so glad back then nobody heard
what I was saying and then you know and
then in six months I'll be like alright
now I figure out so glad when I thought
I figured it out that nobody heard what
I was saying exactly so it's all of
these little little things I don't know
if it I don't know if it was a tangible
off the stage moment but I remember when
I got that joke to two things when I
figured out the title track to my first
album which is I think it just kicked in
that's like a six and a half minute
story about mushrooms when I figured out
how to get that that joke that very
specific hallucinogenic joke to work on
the road where people didn't know who I
was and it's a joke about drugs you know
especially something that not only you
know people our age I guess I've
experienced it but when you go on the
road you're performing for every walk of
life with blue air to you know young to
like who knows you know everything the
nobody really you don't have your people
yet right you know what I'm saying you
know but I got that to work with a
generic audience and I was like okay I
figured something out and then the
second one was when I figured out the
joke about the last time I got hit by my
parents that that figuring out how to
make that work in front of a tourists
crowd about getting beat by my parents I
was like okay I figured something out
and how did you figure that out like
could you take us through kind of the
process of like maybe where the joke
started and the
of reaction it was getting to then how
you're able to mold it into like oh this
is ready for everyone well I mean the
mushroom the mushroom joke is kind of
unfair because that that whole story
happened and the kid gave me the
punchline so that like the guy literally
after four hours of screaming and
flipping out and putting on a you know a
wild drug hazed show he came outside and
then looked at me and goes I think the
mushrooms just kicked in so like that I
just as soon as he said that I was like
bit right like I was on mushrooms that I
typed it into like later and so that
that's almost unfair but the the getting
hit by my parents I was watching a prior
special I forget which one it was but he
was doing this really in-depth like it
almost scene he was acting out this
whole scene and and talking about his
parents you know his mom whooping him
and his grandma you know beating the
[ __ ] out of him and all this stuff and
it was hysterical and then I remembered
I was like oh that we're getting hit and
I remember the story and I remember my
mom swinging and I caught her hands and
I immediately thought I was like oh that
might be funny or something like that
and I just kind of took it out and
talked about it on stage loosely and I'm
a better writer on stage than I am in my
home so I'm studious to the point where
I listen to my sets and I write down the
stuff and then I organize it from there
but I'll bring I'll bring a chunk or an
idea on the stage and my fear will help
fill in the funny a little bit you know
to me if I'm backed up against the wall
and I have nothing to say and there's a
group of people looking at me you know
just waiting waiting for me to say
something interesting
typically my body out of sheer you know
reaction will have something or if it
doesn't I'll just die on stage what yeah
what is the success rate of that I feel
like fear guiding you like how many
times will you try something out of fear
that works versus doesn't work so the
premise itself like I if I already if I
know the premise is something I want to
be worked working on I'll bring it out
for a long
long time but and and I'll fail with it
I don't care I'll couch it in-between
bits at work I will you know I'll make
sure that doesn't submarine the show but
this working out in New York City the
best part is that you can do so many
spots in a night right so I can run
through about you know six different
tags in one night and have an idea of
what works the best for the next night
so there's a lot of crowds that probably
see me and it's the only time they'll
ever be exposed to my comedy and be like
well that was a forgettable pile of [ __ ]
and then they'll never he'll never go
see me again which is totally fine but
then hopefully by the time the finished
product is out and then you know you
showcase it to whoever is interested
it's it's fully formed and ready so back
to Liam's question about what made you
grow faster and better as a joke writer
is it being willing to sit in that fear
and face it and try to create in that
moment yeah I think so I I think that's
exactly right is you know your worst
fear when you start out as bombing and
then you bomb and you're like yeah
that's that's just about just as bad as
I anticipated I think it is it's it's
soul-crushing it's heart-wrenching I
take it really personally because my
material is so personal it's not that
they just don't like my jokes it's that
they don't like me as a human being
right which is true yeah I've sent into
a lot of people that just don't like me
on a personal level and it just is what
it is so you know after a while you're
just you just got to be okay with
yourself and be like well I find this
good and I've workshop did enough with
enough people that I know I know it's
relatable to at least you know a sect of
humanity okay and suburi
actually followed up here he's actually
from India he's actually tuning i from
india Saberi shibori and he says like
please share your writing process and
maybe that can also be part of like you
try stuff out on stage more than on the
page so then are you recording your set
how are you refining and grading stuffs
you know so my entire process top to
bottom is I you know I'm either in
conversation I'm I'm an on-the-fly
writer I certainly sit down to edit and
organize and stuff like that I do I am
studious on that level but I'm an
on-the-fly writer where like I say a lot
of things in conversation that I think
are good enough for stage immediately so
if I say something in conversation I'll
just be like all right hold that thought
shut up shut up in the middle of a
social gathering and then just write
down what I just said and then take it -
you know I I try to remember it as best
as possible I take it to stage I forget
75% of it and then kind of that like I
said the fear fills in the gaps so if I
say one or two three four or zero things
at work more after that I'll remember it
I'll write it down I'll try to memorize
that and it just keeps stacking like
that so I'll really you know I I write
try to remember it don't remember it
riff stuff right down that stuff try to
remember that remember some of it riff
write down that stuff so it's all just
kind of constant like paraphrasing of my
own ideas until eventually it becomes
strong and you said you're studious in
the editing process of it like what is
what is goes into the axial editing and
do you record all your sets and listen
back are you all just trying to remember
everything I do I record my sets
I could be better at listening back what
I am very good at though is getting off
stage and immediately writing down
something that works that's cool so and
and a lot of my sets that like yeah I so
I marked down my sets let me I'll pull
it up real quick
I marked down I'd marked down my sets I
don't know if you could see that's
probably too much but it says like New
York Comedy Club riff heavy New York
Comedy Club new tag Taylor Swift
contract eat it like E I so I'll have
certain notes of like this is at 5:35 I
said this so it's stuff that I like I go
back to listen to rate to see if it
works as well as I remember to reword it
write it down so it is all that editing
stuff that to me is the most painful but
it's the most necessary is you just go
you have to relist into yourself even
though I mean there's nothing that makes
you want to hurt yourself more yeah
that's something I think all comedians
are like yeah record everything but I
listen to like 10% of it but I could
write write
I learned from preparing for my comedy
special that whoa this is very valuable
but it's kind of like having your back
against the wall of like well you have
this deadline to film this thing so it
better be ready so it's like you have to
do the work and it's if you want comedy
to be your job at some point you got to
start treating it like a job yeah yeah
hundred percent man I mean and nothing
has taught me that even more than this
quarantine to be perfectly honest
because you know it's easy to go out
every night and do spots and write
comedy and and stuff like that this this
quarantine has actually forced me to now
become a technical and technical savvy
person I'm doing podcasts on zoom' I
just bought all this new equipment I
have to edit my own my own clips like
all this stuff so it's forced me out of
my comfort zone where you know I'm not
saying comedy is easy at all it's not at
all but I'm saying that I've been doing
it for over eleven years to the point
where I've gotten into a rhythm on how
to achieve you know my end goal so this
being not able to go on stage and just
focus on other aspects of the career has
it's been an invaluable lesson actually
yeah and what was your marketing with
your special because my biggest I would
say my biggest weakness is I'm not
afraid of the work I'm not afraid of
doing things but it's like as soon as I
achieve something then I'm just like
okay what's next so it's like Sheriff I
filmed the special released it and then
was like okay what's next what's next I
didn't even think about marketing or
what the end goal of this was and my my
personal strategy was looking at
everyone giving away their special I was
like well let me try the opposite and
let me try to sell it so I'm actually
selling it through my website with the
whole goal like if I break even my whole
goal is to break even yeah just show
other comics that this is possible to do
you know what I mean so like what was
your thinking in terms of okay the
creative side of it and the production
side and all that but then like okay
what am I gonna get out of this in a
sense at that makes sense so my my whole
marketing plan was the SPECIAL itself is
45 minutes right it's got about 31
minutes of stand-up comedy and then the
rest is interstitial and even the extra
the credit footage
which was me dealing with a heckler
during the second recording which is
ridiculous but my whole point my whole
thought process was okay I will not
release the full hour on the special so
I'm gonna give away about 30 minutes
after that hopefully that will act as a
business card to then advertise for the
full our audio album once the audio
album was out then I was starting to cut
up the extra minutes that extra half
hour into Clips I'd roll that out on
Instagram and on YouTube and then I also
have been well we'll start chopping up
the actual special and putting those
into individual clips as well so it
gives me you know it's work than it
hasn't at the same time like you know
this is all trial and error it's you put
out the piece my piece did pretty well
it I wish it could have you know gotten
even higher numbers but it is what it is
it still lives on the internet and will
forever now with the rolling out of the
individual clips that gives people
something to digest that's smaller right
so if they watch that and they're like
oh I want to see more of that maybe
they'll go to another clip I want to
watch more than that oh [ __ ] this guy is
a full special let me watch this whole
special you know so it's all it's all
just trying to cast a wide net in hopes
of bringing people back to the main
project so you put out a bunch of like
micro content hoping to funnel them into
the full special to then exact see you
live and to listen to your podcast is
that kind of that yeah that that's the
entire thing man is you know before
before recently live live comedy was how
I made 100 percent of my money for the
most part and now now I'm lucky to where
you know I I get residuals from from
both of my albums at this point and I
get a I make a little bit of money off
of my podcast as well so that stuff is
keeping me afloat during this time but
the idea for me I love stand-up I'm I'm
a stand-up comedian I I can act
I enjoy doing that stuff it's super fun
but I want all of that stuff to fund my
stand-up yes so if I if I can't or if I
can continue to create and if I can
continue to do stuff that I want to do
that is centered around me being a live
performer that's that's the end-all
be-all
man you know everybody wants to turn you
into something else but I just love
stand up yeah we're what now yeah all of
us comics are in quarantine what do we
do - Lee this this is the only thing you
could do you know I see people do the
live IG lives they end up stuff and you
know more power to you if you're gonna
do that I personally listen I I did a
lot of open mics for know people for a
long time I'm not trying to do that in
my living yes Sean Patton was on here
last week and he was saying he did a
zoom show that had like 15 audience
members in it it was like okay it was
like they're starting to grow beyond
just like comics riffing with each other
so we're trying to figure it out here I
think that you know it it could be cool
it's just like right now I think it's
difficult because everybody's online so
the the traffic is slammed so with even
like slight delay stuff it's fine when
we're in a one-on-one conversation but
you're trying to deliver a joke and then
like you're in the middle of the first
two words of your next sentence and I'm
finally here laughs from your last joke
it could throw off everything yeah it's
interesting thinking about your your
comedy special as well and that you did
just throw it on YouTube in terms of
even did you even try to like zahaan
actually who's actually up in Canada
zahana
he said his special is free like it's on
YouTube so totally different marketing
but did you at first try to pitch it to
a Netflix or anything like that or um I
don't think I don't think we sent it to
Netflix because I thought that was just
an unreasonable goal to set they I know
who they're looking at at this point and
I my hopes was to create this special
and gained interest from them for a
future project or to gain interest from
another network
I believe we sent it to Comedy Central
we may have even sent it to Amazon as
well but I was pretty gung-ho on just
giving it away in the you know giving
part of the material away and then
hopefully leading it and making my money
back on the audio end to where I was I
was totally fine with just putting
up on YouTube because all I wanted was
as many eyes on it as humanly possible
so in its it's funny man you know right
before right before all this I sold out
my first comedy club you know and it was
all based on the special it was all
based on the podcast I was doing to
promote the special a lot of people came
out from that so I think I think we're
looking at you know the NBA talks a lot
about the player empowerment period
right where you know guys are teaming up
together and they're they're tampering
just on an individual player thing
because they have they realized that
they have to leverage they have the name
they're the ones that are selling the
tickets and now I think we're in a
comedian empowerment period where comics
are starting to realize it's like
alright you know if I put this out for
free then I'm gonna make money on the
back end it's all an investment back
into yourself so you know I started up
because the Comedy Cellar is so great
and so generous they give you a hundred
percent of the door that's when you from
think oh my god so I did through
sold-out shows at the Village Lantern or
Village Underground which is their big
space and that's how I was able to pay
for my production that's how I was able
to pay for my time that's how you know I
was able to start from a place of not
panic so if I had to make up a ten
fifteen thousand dollar nut then I would
have been much more much more aggressive
about selling it how did you market it
to sell out to shows that was also that
was me doing radio and podcasts all all
radio and podcast so I did Jim Norton
and Sam Roberts on Sirius a few times I
did Ari Shaffir as podcast I think
really helped push it over the top
because he just has a huge fan base and
he just slammed home that people should
come and and check this out and this is
how people are I mean he's you know
whatever you may think about his Kobe
joke Ari is a very good guy that that
really cares about his fellow comedians
so I I couldn't be more appreciative to
him for the help to sell those shows out
that's what's so bizarre but that
situation is like people are like like
comics like he's the nicest guy like I
don't get like why some people are like
he's done this with everyone that's died
and then other people are like he's
literally the nicest guy I've ever met
this does not this does not show who he
actually is as a person so it's such a
bizarre like contrast there yeah it's
one of those things where he does do
that with everybody that dies I think he
grossly underestimated Kobe Bryant's
reach and who who holds him dear yeah
because you know I think he just thought
it would be like one of those things I
just yeah he says it gets a chuckle from
his fans and then it gets swept under
the rug or whatever he didn't understand
that Kobe Bryant is an international
beloved person yeah you know and I that
was just a swing and a miss you know
have you talked to her since that
happened yeah he seems totally fine
oh no no remorse or like maybe not I I
mean I'm sure I don't know yeah on that
level there there might be might be some
of them but I think listen I think if
you're if you're if your intent is to is
to be funny then then that's kind of all
you can ask for when people are trying
to call for your head for making a joke
and then you respond with an apology it
kind of admits that you weren't kidding
because the only defense for a joke is I
was kidding you know I have a six-minute
chunk about circumcision you know unlike
special that I then put out individually
on YouTube and I had to take it down
individually because it just got flooded
with anti-circumcision maniacs it just
like how dare you cut into your innocent
child's penis and he'll never forgive
you this is exactly like a circumcised
victim you piece of [ __ ] like just
people that are like you know it's it's
madness and like at first I was having
fun kind of like that and I'm around
like a cat but after a while you just
gets flooded by these maniacs and it's
like you guys are so done like I'm just
kidding I don't know what's going on
here there's there's really nothing to
defend besides like you guys are the
ones trying to hurt feelings I actually
set out with the intent to make you
laugh and this actually ties into the
next question from Julio who asked how
does a comic develop thick skin hmm
if you find out let me
no I I thought I feel like I have I have
on some level and and definitely have
grown used to taking a beating a little
bit but it still bothers me everything
still bothers me there's still you know
and I'm I'm not at the level where I
feel comfortable not looking at my
comments I'm still in dire need of
support and of you know generating
interest and an audience to the point
where I respond to everybody on Twitter
rich boss made fun of me for that like
the when my special was coming out I was
responding to every single person saying
thank you for watching thank you I
appreciate it thank you thank you and
rich is like hey stupid why don't you
act like you're famous already Lisp down
I know I just
I actually just completely wet Mikey's
boss but I'm still at that point where
like you know I've gotten better at kind
of shrugging off a few things but but
I'm you know I'm a comic I'm a sensitive
guy that that's what makes me funny and
that's also what hurts me but I think
that's a generational thing in terms of
I feel like comics and are like
generation it because I'm 10 years and
you're 11 years in so I mean and you're
like developing in New York I mean
you're you're like 20 years compared to
someone who's developing and like
smaller scenes in terms of just skillset
but like I feel like comedians now not
like a rich vos who's on the other end
of the spectrum but like comedians
coming up and building fans it's like
part of our job is to now interact with
if someone comments it is kind of like
responding making like making sure
they're heard and feel a part of your
fan base and feel like invested in you
and your journey you know I think that's
something we it's part of the job now
well I think I think so also because
there are so many options right like so
if you don't they can easily find
another comedian who will so there's
funny people that are also then also
very accessible and I I would like to be
both up until a point I would also like
to be able to shut it off a little bit
yeah but it does it it makes such a
difference I think long term with we're
investing in our fans of the future even
doing a QA like this and like having
people get to ask their own questions
you know a lot of my interviews before
the quarantine well none of them were
via Skype it was all in person but now
I'm like hey we've built this community
let's all try to figure this out
together and the QA that's what people
wanted to hear so now we're doing it
well and now it's great you could get
guests that you know I don't know when I
would have come down to Atlanta so yeah
I would hope to be booked there as soon
as possible but I don't have anything on
the book so it's great that we can you
know the quarantine almost like forced
it to happen it's great it really did
because I was in this mindset of it has
to be in person or not it's like I've
I've been offered phone interviews and
I'm like no I'll wait till we get it in
person type deal but now it is like just
by any means necessary
I'll just you know let's just make it
happen so it was all kind of making
lemons wood lemonade in terms of the
situation we're in
but let's get into let's let's land this
plane here we have Carter he's actually
he's actually out in Arkansas he he
jumped in on the Sean Patton Q&A last
week and he was actually planning to
move to New York but before all of this
happened it's like now Ground Zero which
I think you got out of there didn't you
did you yeah we came to my hometown
pretty early just because I lived in
Brooklyn the the Bloods that were living
on my front stoop were not practicing
social distancing so I figured it was
safer to get my wife and small child out
of there and give him space and allow
him to be outside as opposed to cooped
up in the two-bedroom apartment smart so
he asked Carter asked do you think the
NYC comedy scene eventually returns back
to normal no I mean well there's gonna
be a new normal it's not gonna be what
we thought I have I have a feeling that
this might shut er a club or two for
sure you know there's a lot of people
including comedians are operating on
razor thin margins
and you know as you can see there's a
lot of lot of GoFundMe is going around
from clubs to help help support their
staff and things like that which you
know I'm all I'm all for as long as one
of the owners isn't a Bitcoin
billionaire sorry I'll leave it vague
the coin billionaire yeah he certainly
owns one of the one of the upper
Westside clubs that is now asking for
you know money for their [ __ ] okay
stat for Westside it's a he okay New
York I love those guys I would just hope
that like they you know it just seems a
bit silly to start a GoFundMe for their
staff when when one of their owners is
literally a billionaire that just that
to me seems seems an odd way the odd way
to go about things but whatever yeah I
think that I think they'll survive it
they're a great club and they'll be back
but there's a couple other places that
you know like I said they're operating
razor thin margins they're trying to
make their way through this as much as
any performer is so you know could be
far less comedy clubs could be more
alternative venues you know bars maybe
start looking more into comedy because
they need to you know they need to pick
up on a Tuesday night or whatever so it
could it could be a little bit more
guerrilla when we get back as opposed to
you know the 9.com proper comedy clubs
that it was beforehand so what cake what
cake comedians do what are you saying
comedians do in terms of in this current
like time like what are you seeing
working or what are you seeing
experimenting with or what are you what
are you going to do even what I'm
continuing to do is to post my stand-up
Clips I'm now you know because
everything is content-heavy at this
point and there is no opportunity to
make a person-to-person connection I'm
now posting clips you know five times a
week maybe six times a week so I'm doing
stand-up clips I'm doing other like you
know I did a guy named crammin who runs
his own music festival because I dyed my
hair pink when I got bored like the
second day of quarantine um you know I'm
just doing stupid characters I did one
you know
anything that you can do to just put out
content and try to hit with anything is
is beneficial and now I'm also I'm doing
a patreon I see a lot of comedians that
are really not only surviving but
flourishing on a patreon and it's
something that Mike Feeny and I who he's
my co-host for Irish goodbye podcast we
had talked about it for a long time but
we we are on gas digital network so we
have our own separate agreement with
them where we provide extra extra
content for for their subscribers and we
see a little bit of money off of that
but now we've started a secondary
project myself Feeney and Brendan's
aglow where it's gonna be entirely
patreon it's behind a paywall its
wildest [ __ ] it's a-you know and
hopefully we can take some of our fans
from our podcasts and also you know
accumulate some new ones and help
support and make some money so is that
how does gas digital work cuz you
mentioned you make some money from your
podcast is that all through sponsorships
underneath gas digital how does that
produce yeah the network yeah so we we
get money we get money for sponsorships
we also get money for when people sign
up to gas digital using the code IGP we
get a little cut of that so each time
somebody becomes a member and they use
our specific code we get a cut of that
but then everybody that uses any code
gets full access to every single show
that's on the network so you get all
their extra footage you get all their
episodes you get all their videos all
that stuff so some people that may a
joined because of Legion a skank switch
is their most popular podcast and kind
of their cornerstone show they can then
maybe bleed over into Irish goodbye but
we don't see that money we just see the
the you know influx and in listens and
that also dictates our advertisement
Christ but for patreon that's kind of a
direct direct to fan thing almost you
know farm-to-table right you have you
want to you want to hopefully serve it
up to your most loyal and diehard fans
where you're like alright listen we're
putting in the effort we're putting in
we're doing extra episodes we're doing
videos we're doing we're listening to
you guys we're hoping to create that
community you know we just were talking
about that we're reaching out to your
listeners and and saying thank you and
being accessible is great
now patreon provides
legitimate community for you and your
fans to exist in and it be cut and you
guys are you're right there in the same
space shooting shooting the [ __ ] sharing
ideas all that stuff and they are they
are active participants in our in our
patreon so yeah that's what I love about
having a patreon for this show is it's
like the Facebook group is like one
level of interaction and connection but
it's like people that join the patreon
are like ride-or-die they're looking to
take this they're looking to take this
relationship to the next level you know
what I mean for sure
yeah so is that available now like can
they please let them know if that goes
to support so it's coming out tomorrow
early perfect okay yeah it's a Brendon
sagol Oh Mike Feeny Mike and myself
we're doing a podcast called what's the
scenario where it's basically a
hypothetical type podcast where we bring
out you know would you rather is what
ifs certain questions you know and we're
gonna take questions from audience
members and we basically start with the
question and of course it takes
tangential turns and to god-knows-where
we tell stories we trash each other we
you know we're very much involved with
our audience and and whoever has
specific comments we will interact and
address those so it's a it's a little
bit all over the place but it's fun as
hell and I think people will really like
it I love it
creating like a new podcast it's almost
like your own TV channel that's great
yeah exactly that's right dude Mike
thank you so much for doing this I I
just I think we share the same mindset
in terms of and it took me years to get
this mindset that I think comics have to
hammer home is like just focus on what
you can control and just start doing
your own things start creating and
you're a prime example of that and
that's why I was so excited get you on
here is because comics coming up and
developing a lot we are in our own heads
and there is a lot of self-doubt and
there is a lot of scarcity mentality and
like me against them but it really is
just kind of don't worry if that Club
doesn't book you don't worry if you
don't get booked on that 3 a.m. bar show
that 12 people show up to it's like
that's how you don't worry you didn't
get on the TV show it's like what can
you control what are you in control of
and what do you want
and just work towards that yeah man show
business is not fair
especially on a corporate level so
anything that you can do as an artist if
you think that you if you got into this
for the love of the game if you got into
this because you love comedy you love
writing and you love performing then do
that try to monetize it figure it out
you know that's and also have confidence
in your in your product because I'm one
of those guys where it took a long time
for me to you know not think that or
yeah for me to not think that the
networks were right you know they say oh
we love you but we're not using you so
what the hell does that mean if I spent
time focusing on that I could drive
myself insane but instead I'm just like
well I think what I'm doing is funny I'm
here in the reaction from people in
real-time and I'm also getting a heavy
flow of things that are coming in online
of people that also identify with this
so so what the hell let's do it yeah you
kind of opened up with that it's like
funny isn't people there aren't looking
for funny anymore like I mean that's a
that's a fun that's like fifth on the
list you know and so I'm not trying to
trash anybody mainstream because people
are doing what they're doing and they're
making some money and good for them I
would never take that away from anybody
but there is a system in place that is
not necessarily rewarding people that
are spending the real time and effort
mastering stand-up comedy what have you
seen from what has been the result of
the special or your podcast numbers up
are like engagement up like our numbers
up from it I think everything's up like
I said I mean I just I just started
hitting the road basically right after
the special dropped in all those
podcasts dropped and I sold out my first
club I you know that even that first
weekend I had I had a ton of people come
out to wilkes-barre Pennsylvania which
is insane so it's like you know people
that watch it are interested in support
people let you know that that free thing
it doesn't I don't know from what I've
seen it does not it does not go over
people's heads that you put out a
quality product for free when you could
have charged so everybody was like hey
man I want to support now I have I have
a limited t-shirt out right now right so
people that watch my watch my special
and didn't have to financially support
it are now like hey I'll give you 20
bucks
for that t-shirt you gave me an hour
laughs and I get a shirt out of it yeah
I'll spend that money so it's it's it's
all trying to garner favor and garner
support from people that that like what
you do and also think you're going about
it the right way awesome well my cannon
dude thank you so much for banging on
about so earring I don't even know no
this is great
I love I love interviewed comedians
because at some point they're either
like oh I talked too much or none of
that made sense or this is stupid we
always have to like I said I said
something profound but I'm an idiot I
shouldn't that wasn't me yeah you know
guys if you're listening and you thought
I was an idiot you're writing with you
it's totally fine there it is but dude
thank you so much for for taking the
time to do this man I wish you nothing
but the best and maybe any anybody else
maybe we'll get homeless pimp on here
but anybody else we can think I get on
here dude we're just trying to do this
for comics buy comics you know hell yeah
man good luck to you as well and hope
you stay safe and healthy during this
whole thing absolutely thanks Mike hi
brother and thank you to everyone that
asks questions as well we'll be back on
Thursday with Jacob Williams doing
another hot breath live here in the
group so we'll see you then